ET exclusively learned Taylor Swift and
Joe Alwyn called it quits
now a source is giving us insight into
their breakup explaining that the couple
is in totally different places in their
lives right now there's so many moving
parts to this the two split a few weeks
ago after six years of dating and E.T
Source says while it was more the
singer's decision to break up they both
realized neither of them was to quote
Taylor the one
if you would have been the one they had
been together for such a long time and
were spending so much time together but
their personalities were just too
different of course we know Taylor has a
big friend group and entertains hundreds
of thousands of people on stage while
Joe is more introverted shy and quiet
Taylor's currently on her eras World
Tour and our source says the Grammy
winner is staying focused on work
[Music]
adding that she has nothing but respect
for Joe and really loved and enjoyed all
the time and memories they shared they
had a deep connection and she
appreciated that she hopes they can be
friendly in the future
[Music]
foreign
on Saturday E.T exclusively confirmed
that the two split a few weeks ago a
source previously told ET that the
breakup was amicable and not dramatic
the relationship had just run its course
[Music]
but it's not enough cause the mountain
comes and you're not my baby and while
fans will just have to wait and see if
Taylor pins any songs about their split
swifties have speculated that their Love
Inspired several Taylor tracks like
invisible string
[Music]
tying you to me
London boy
[Music]
and gorgeous
as a songwriter there are times when you
are working harder to find the
inspiration and then there are those
random instances where all you have to
do is grab it Joe even famously
collaborated with Taylor on her 2020
album folklore under the actor pseudonym
William Bowery there's been a lot of
discussion about William Bowery and his
identity William Bowery is Joe
as we know as for Taylor the next stop
on our tour is Tampa Florida and it's
safe to say fans will be analyzing every
detail 100 ready for it are you ready
for it
[Music]